foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing what would have
happened in this series if one of Harry
Potter's most well-known antagonists
Draco Malfoy had been sorted into
Gryffindor house instead of Slytherin
for this particular hypothetical
scenario I must admit that the first
question I found myself asking was if
sorted into Gryffindor would Draco have
been more of a Peter Pettigrew or a
serious black that is to say would he
have played the part of a Gryffindor
only to betray his loyalties later and
serve Voldemort in secret as Pettigrew
did or coming from a pure blood family
infamously known for their ties to the
dark lord and dark arts would he have
openly and with pure intentions shirked
his family's affiliations and ideologies
in favor of the greater good and doing
what was right similarly to Sirius Black
personally I believe would have been the
former sorry to any Draco fans out there
but I just can't see young Malfoy
outright abandoning his anti-muggle
sentiments and pure-blooded favoritism
with the drop of a hat sorting out that
is sorry couldn't help myself that said
I think his time at Hogwarts wouldn't
have been nearly as pleasant for him had
he been sorted into Gryffindor I think
eventually he would have found his
footing and been just as confident in
his beliefs as he was pre-sorting
ceremony but at first filled with shock
and horror and not having been placed in
southern as his entire family had been
before him his arrogance and
self-confidence would have been at least
a little bit shaken because as you may
recall he was so certain he would be
sorted into Southern in fact well in
advance of the Sorting ceremony he went
so far as to boast a Harry that he would
most definitely be placed in Slytherin
saying well no one really knows until
they get here do they but I know I'll be
in Slytherin all our family have been so
can you you imagine how completely
shattering it would have been for young
Draco to have been placed in the Rival
House of Gryffindor his certainty in his
future his sense of self his very
identity which had been infuriatingly
boastful before would have been put into
question not to mention what his mother
and father would say about this
absolutely terrible news so I believed
that if Malfoy had been sorted into
Gryffindor we would have been presented
with a more fragile version of Draco at
least at first to begin with he'd feel
isolated and alone having snubbed
several of his fellow gryffindors almost
immediately before the ceremony of
course I'm referring to Ron and Harry I
mean how could we forget how Draco
ruthlessly insulted Ron right before
offering Harry that handshake outside
the Great Hall and prior to that Draco
was so utterly rude to Harry in Diagon
Alley before he knew that he was the
Harry Potter needless to say these two
boys wouldn't have been lining up to
become best mates with the young wizard
with so recently slighted them both so
at least for the first little while I
think Draco would have been a bit of a
loner within Gryffindor House perhaps he
would have tried to bridge the gap
between the houses to keep his
friendships alive with crab and Goyle
the two Hogwarts students who were
previously his Goonies and who were of
course sorted into Southern sadly for
Malfoy most likely both of these boys
wouldn't have had any interest in
keeping company with a Gryffindor and
they certainly wouldn't have wanted to
go back to following draco's every
command imagine following the orders of
a Gryffindor highly unlikely so after a
failed attempt to retain some semblance
of his pre-hogwarts life and Status
Malfoy may have decided to approach some
of the first year Wizards in Gryffindor
perhaps a few students who he thought
could be easily manipulated like he did
with crab and Goyle in an effort to
rebuild a new little crew for himself I
could see him approaching a pure ritual
wizard like say lavender brown or
Neville Longbottom now I can't really
see Neville falling in too tight with
Draco considering his parents have been
tortured to Insanity by Death Eaters one
of whom was Bellatrix Lestrange draco's
aunt but it's possible someone like
lavender may have been interested in
building a friendship with a potentially
powerful young wizard from a pure
blooded family like Malfoy and so Draco
could have made nalayo II in this way
within Gryffindor eventually I'd like to
think that Harry and Ron would have
decided to give Draco a second chance
after all it wasn't in either of their
Natures to be deliberately cruel so
perhaps in second or third year they
would have started including Malfoy in
more things talking to him during meal
times that kind of thing perhaps they
would have even taken it upon themselves
to encourage Draco to be more
open-minded about Bloodlines pushing him
to give Hermione and others a chance
despite their blood status and 4
survival reasons I think Draco would
have accepted Harry and Ron's efforts
even tolerating Hermione as a friend but
I also think he would have continued to
look down on her and most likely lied to
his family about having any mudblood
friends at school after all how could he
go home each holiday and not retain his
misguided perceptions of The Wizarding
World when his entire family was so
steadfast in their beliefs and loyalties
to the dark lord and as briefly
mentioned Bellatrix Lestrange was his
aunt and she was of course quite
terrifying with relatives like this it
was so close with Voldemort himself it's
hard to imagine Draco being able to
fully embrace the Gryffindor ideologies
and relinquish his family's loyalties
and anti-muggle beliefs if he had and
been found out best case scenario he may
have been banished from his family worst
case killed so what would this have
meant for Draco personally I think it
would have resulted in some want to have
a double life for him pacifying the
likes of Harriet's school with the
perception that he'd become more
open-minded and hey maybe sometimes he
even believed it himself but for the
most part I think Draco would have still
felt above mudbloods and would have felt
duty-bound to uphold his family's honor
ultimately I believe this would have
meant that we wouldn't have heard as
much about Malfoy for the majority of
the novels and films perhaps he would
have been featured about the same amount
as Say Never long bottom then as we
progressed through the series he would
have become more of a focal point as I
do think Draco would have still been
selected by Voldemort to assassinate
Dumbledore he might have even been an
even more desirable candidate for this
task actually with his increased
accessibility to Harry who was of course
very close with Dumbledore what's more
there likely would have been less
suspicion about Draco being involved in
a secret task for the dark lord Snape
being the triple agent that he was still
would have taken on the unbreakable vow
to protect Malfoy but since he wouldn't
have been the head of draco's house
anymore they would have had to
communicate more secretively personally
I think it would have been really
interesting to have not known too much
about where draco's true loyalties lay
throughout the series similarly to Snape
it would have been quite intriguing to
have always been guessing whether or not
we could trust Malfoy we may have been
constantly asking ourselves whether he
had actually changed even just a little
in the actual events of Harry Potter we
do get glimpses of Draco wavering in his
loyalties to Voldemort later in the
series so it's possible that he could
have converted to fully supporting the
likes of Dumbledore Harry and the Order
of the Phoenix instead of Voldemort in
the Death Eaters however just because
someone doesn't want to blindly follow
the orders of a mass murdering dark
wizard doesn't necessarily mean that
they are moral and good does it and as
we've already discussed I think it would
have been very difficult for Malfoy to
outright abandon that believes he'd held
for so long especially with the views of
his parents Lucius and Narcissa with
whom he remained close as a young wizard
all in all if Draco had been sorted into
Gryffindor I think Malfoy would have
been a more complex and mysterious
character earlier in the series he would
have kept us guessing just like Snape
but he mostly would remain the same
person in terms of his beliefs and been
involved in the same major events that
occurred such as its attempted
assassination of Dumbledore this of
course brings us to the end of this
video do you agree how do you think the
series would have differed if Draco had
been sorted into Gryffindor would he
have been a Peter Pettigrew or
mysterious black let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed the video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time imagine being in
Hufflepuff I think I'd leave wouldn't
you